all right luna hi hi
luna uh tell me about uh
your life where'd you grow up
um california but everywhere
so you're a california girl yeah cali
girl and you grew up with both parents
no
who'd you grow up in
well so
i grew up with my mom and my stepdad
from one years old until six
and then i got taken away into foster
care
really at what age six years old what
happened
um
i was being
abused and molested
by who um my mom and my stepdad
yeah my mom was um hitting me and stuff
and all that
and then your stepdad was yeah molesting
you
and my sister and your sister too yeah
so they lost both of you
and then my older brother too
wow it must have been bad
yeah it was pretty bad
but that's okay
and did you end up with another family
after that i ended up with a lot of
families i was moving like
every six months
and then um
i was being
touched and stuff at my foster homes and
stuff and then
i went back home
for
about a year
and then i got taken away again
a month before my 13th birthday
because i went to church one day and my
pastor's
wife saw a whole bunch of bruises all
over my body
and called the cops
and then the cops came
and the cruisers were from who my mom
she had just beat me the day before
so
yeah
wow that's a rough childhood
yeah i've had a pretty rough childhood
my mom broke my jaw when i was four
years old jesus never took me to the
hospital
you know
never really worried about
her kids you know
just about drugs
your mom was doing drugs yeah my mom was
big druggie but she's doing better now
and so you have your
biological mom
and then you have other families that
took care of you as well later on
so i have my biological mother but she
lost parental rights over me
um i just started talking to my um real
mom when i turned 18 because i had ran
away from foster care at 16
because
i was being hit and abused and
moved all the time and so
i got put into a group home because i
hit a certain age where
in foster care
when you hit a certain age and you've
been in it for so long and you haven't
had a steady home they're gonna put you
in a group home because then you're
a bad child
even though you're not a bad kid
so
basically i was being starved and my
foster parents were locking the fridge
and stuff and wouldn't beat us and i
would tell my social worker and she
wouldn't believe me so i ended up
leaving
wow and what what age were you when you
finally went on your own 16 16.
did you finish high school
you didn't
and
what kind of kid were you back then were
you a troublemaker or not really you
were a good kid i was never a bad kid i
was a really good kid i think because i
went through so much and
trying to find a family that you fit in
i can't i'm gonna cry
it's okay
yeah
um
and then where'd your life go after that
um
pretty good
i'm sorry no no it's all okay
everybody does there's a lot of stuff
it's like flashing back in my head just
look at it as a therapy session
i didn't really like my therapist
and so
at 16 17 18 you're on your own and what
were you doing um
so um i had moved in with um
my boyfriend and stuff but
he was basically
a drug addict and stuff
and so then he
you know introduced drugs to me and
stuff
and so i tried him
but i didn't like him
i didn't like the way it made me feel or
the thoughts that i put in my head or
anything so like i didn't
do it anymore but he still did so then
he became
very abusive
and stuff
so
basically i was just living that kind of
life for a long time
and what kind of jobs were you doing
um i wasn't
really doing any jobs i was basically
just trying to
stay hidden so i wouldn't get put back
into foster care because i knew i wasn't
going to be better off in foster care
because i was just going to keep going
to the same stuff
yeah nobody was going to
care about me i was just another kid
that
whose parents didn't want her you know
and
and then what happened after after that
you
so basically after that um and i turned
18 i found out i was pregnant
and i had my first kid which is my world
he's my best friend
and
then after i had him though i started
going back to school and then i had to
quit school because i had to focus more
on him
and
basically
i didn't finish school but i only have
like five credits left of math to do so
i'm almost there
but um
and then i ended up getting into
the porn industry
how did you first
get introduced to that um
so
weirdly odd to say i was going on
craigslist looking for modeling jobs
and um i ended up finding a talent scout
or whatever and um
he said that i was really pretty and i
could do the modeling and everything but
it was porn
so like i had talked to um basically my
my husband about it and stuff
and
he's very open my husband he's very
open with me i try to explain to him
about my feelings and my intentions and
everything so he's very
understanding and he knows what i've
been through so
he he doesn't try to
you know
i put a weight too much on me and he he
tries to
instead of bombard me with questions and
making me feel some type of way he just
tries to listen that's great
it's unusual yeah he's he's really good
he's my rock so like basically i went on
to my first
shoot
but i was a fluffer so i had like the
lube and like i was there like hey
how's the eye candy basically
and um
i fell in love with it because of
how open everybody was at their body and
how
like the guys made the girls feel
comfortable and the girls made the guys
feel comfortable and everybody's smiling
and laughing is just like having fun but
it's taking photos and other things
you know so basically i fell in love
with it
at that moment and i knew i wanted to do
it but i still had that dream
in my heart of wanting to be a model
yeah you know so
yeah
yeah i don't
i don't know that you can really do both
very well
at the same time
maybe
you'll be the first you know just model
wall
and
eventually you got into being an actress
and being on camera yep and then i um as
soon as i did that then um i talked with
some agencies and stuff and then i met
my agent and he seemed very nice and
like you know for a first time you know
he was very like
on the dot of like what should be going
on and what should happen and stuff and
everything so i felt very comfortable
you make good money doing it um so
when i was doing it i was making real
good money so i was
making bank and then like i took a break
for a while because i had a lot of stuff
going on and stuff so i needed to
basically re-cleanse myself and get
everything right and everything so
i'm just now getting back into it i've
been back into it for about two months
now and i'm doing good good yeah do are
you involved in drugs or alcohol like
that i smoke marijuana yeah that's
that's like aspirin now that is a plant
no i don't really
drink if i drink i like whiskey i'm a
whiskey gal you know um i don't really
like any kind of
drug i mean i want to try shrooms
cause i heard it's a really good
psychedelic trip
but that's about it
so what what is it what are your
favorite things about being a porn
actress what are the upsides and
downsides so the upside about being a
porn actress honestly is like i kind of
have a high sex drive you know i love
what makes people click i like to know
like the different kinds of
turn-ons i don't know like i'm that
person that like
i want to find out what turns you on
because that's going to turn me on you
know so there's so many
different kinds of people in the
industry that i never knew about and
then it intrigues me i don't know how to
else fixate but it really does intrigue
me
um the downfalls about point
sometimes you get weirdo
yeah i'm sure
i mean do you go to the grocery store
and all of a sudden somebody recognizes
yeah sometimes those are just weirdos or
like people that just want to
write weird stuff to you on your
instagrams and stuff and it's just like
and then they start cussing you out
because like
you don't want to look at their dick
pics
so i don't know
but there's not really too many
downfalls i mean we get tested every
month and if you don't come out with a
clean test they don't work so that's one
thing i also
have that security blanket when i work
is i know i'm gonna be safe i know i'm
going to be taken care of but i know i'm
not going to be disrespected because at
any point in time i feel that way the
shoot stops and i get paid still so i
never have to feel like something bad is
going to happen because a lot of
protections in place correct there's a
lot of protection in place for the girls
but at the same time it's all about
agency who's your agent you know because
there are some agencies out there that
are not good agencies you know and a lot
of girls are open to communicate with
other models and stuff and let them know
their personal opinions on stuff so
inside of
you know agencies is really good so
getting to know other models and other
actresses in the field definitely does
help um instead of going at it blindly
definitely do research does does
being a you know doing what you do for
for work affect your marriage
no your personal life no i mean i mean
being romantic with your husband must be
i mean
you what you did this afternoon is
probably
kind of
you know it's hard for me to wrap my
head around doing that she did that all
day and now now we're sitting on the
sofa together no it doesn't bother him
for him
like i said there's so many different
things that people are turned on to um
my husband actually is turned on to
watching me have sex
and stuff so he actually gets turned on
by that so at that point i'm like okay
hey
you found the right guy though yeah
like i said he accepts me you know he
thinks i'm beautiful even when i'm
sitting there throwing up and pooping
myself you know
he loves you you know so he accepts me
that's great yeah
well luna thank you so much for talking
to me nope sorry about crying no i had
to stop myself i was like
it's okay we're all human we are we went
through
aliens you went through stuff it was
hard i did i'm sorry i didn't open up a
little bit more
what else was there to talk about i
don't know a lot
really yeah we can still we can still i
can edit it together if you want to go
further
that's a lot believe me that's why i
started crying because it's like it all
just started what did i miss i don't
know like so i have ptsd because of a
lot of
stuff that happened to me so
sometimes it's very hard for me to
express
what i'm feeling
inside yeah or
say what's going on in my head because i
shut down you know
i don't mean to it's just
i think when you've been hurt so much in
life you have a wall you know what i
mean
i'm going to pry so
i'm telling you right i'm sorry but what
i mean you're molested and that's
certainly as traumatic as you can
imagine yeah what what else
was there that was so um ptsd closing
uh
you know molested abused
you know being abandoned not only by my
mom and dad but by my sister
you know because when we went back into
foster care she said that she didn't
want to take care of me anymore
and that she was taking care of me my
whole life
so i ended up being in foster care by
myself all by yourself and you have an
older sister
and i was all by myself
moving all the time while my brother and
sister
were just
they just got lucky
[Music]
life sucks
and then you die yeah but your attitude
seems really great you know
i can't i i wouldn't even detect
anything like what you've told me went
on with you
because you seem so like light on your
feet well and easy to smile
the thing is that i've come to
conclusion within my life is that
i can't change anything that happened to
me
and i can't go back in the past and
i can't dwell on it for the rest of my
life or else i'm not going to go
anywhere so the only thing i can do is
embrace it
have it empower me and push me forward
to not be
somebody i don't want to be
figuring out ways to let go of anger is
the key to
honestly it's the key it's not saying
that you ever forget because it's things
you will never forget but it's forgiving
for me for the inside of me so i can
move on with my life instead of having
people have power over me that's how i
can talk to my mom
that's how i can
talk to my family and everything is
because i don't let them have the power
if they hurt me
and i prove to them wrong every single
day that i'm still pushing forward and
i'm still becoming the person i want to
be even though i came from nothing
and i had no help
from anybody
i still [ __ ] did it
and i'm proud of myself you should be
[ __ ]
thank you so much no problem